las Fuertes lluvias en inundaciones en
el centro de China han dejado ya 15
muertos y cuatro desaparecidos en la
ciudad de chonching y han forzado la
evacuación de casi 100.000 personas en
la provincia de sichuan es el último de
los fenómenos climáticos extremos que
sufre el país en las últimas semanas y
que están relacionados con el niño y es
según los pronósticos solo el principio
las autoridades meteorológicas han
advertido de que el país sufrirá en este
mes de julio múltiples desastres
naturales como inundaciones sequías
tifones y altas temperaturas Y es que
está siendo un verano muy intenso el mes
pasado aquí en Beijing se contaron 14
días por encima de los 35 grados y
varios por encima de los 40 fue el junio
más caluroso desde que se empezaron a
tomar registros hace 60 años en toda
china 70 estaciones apuntaron récords de
temperatura históricos y junto al calor
extremo el país también sufre de sequía
las lluvias han caído más del 50% en una
provincia húmeda del sureste y más de 3
millones de de cultivo han quedado
afectadas las altas temperaturas han
disparado el gasto de energía
especialmente por los aparatos de aire
acondicionado lo que ha provocado ya
cortes en varias zonas los fenómenos
extremos como las inundaciones No son
nuevos en China de hecho el país tiene
su historia numerosos y dramáticos
desbordamientos de ríos pero alertan los
expertos de que estos fenómenos cada vez
empiezan antes y cada vez duran más
china es uno de los países más afectados
por el cambio climático por su enorme
población y tamaño y por la escasez de
recursos acuíferos